Vsauce Kevin here kids in the US haven't
always had summers off in rural areas
they went to school in summer and winter
to help during planting and harvesting
while urban kids went year-round in the
mid-1800s school shifted to a
standardized fall spring schedule
allowing for family vacations and to
give relief from buildings with no
air-conditioning and doctors at the time
supported this saying that summers off
would also help protect kids brains from
overuse meanwhile kids are getting
smarter the Flynn effect shows that IQ
scores improved markedly with each
generation professor James Flynn found
that if students 100 years ago took
today's IQ test
they'd average 70 all of students today
took the test 100 years ago they'd
average 130 explanations include better
health care nutrition and more schooling
and the fact that people before the
scientific age were often adverse to
classifying things they couldn't use and
did it routinely engage in hypothetical
or abstract thought neuropsychologist AR
Luria tested this on a socially isolated
farmer about a hundred years ago and it
went something like this what do a
chicken and a dog have in common
nothing chicken has two legs dogs have
four chickens have wings dogs don't all
right you've explained how they're
different but how are they alike they're
not all right is there one word though
that you could use for both of them nope
what about animal with the word animal
fit yes online courses are commonplace
now but Sir Isaac Pitman actually
established the first distance learning
course in the 1840s Pitman taught
shorthand by mailing postcards to
students and correcting the answers that
they mailed back in the 1920s
educational radio programs were
considered textbooks in the air and
today there are over 2,200 courses
available online around the world for
free while South Korea is using robot
teachers to help children with learning
disabilities a kindergarten in
Switzerland is breeding
education back to its roots literally
they have a school outside in the forest
where kids attend rain or snow learning
to build shelters and fires alongside
their ABCs and as always whoa thanks for
watching
it's school of YouTube week and you can
make a difference to the millions of
children worldwide who won't be going
back to school this year whether due to
lack of teachers school materials or
worse so click on the donate button if
you can to help spread ideas and
knowledge to everyone
you